vous aimez les cookies moi aussi et pour
Noël on va se faire plaisir d'autant
plus quand on va aller les chercher chez
les artisans
[Musique]
locaux pierre et team ce sont deux amis
yvelinois qui se sont lancés en 2015
dans la création de cookies originaux
fait maison et sans conservateur pour
Noël la marque vous propose de composer
vos propres coffrets en fonction de vos
goûts et ce à partir de 5 € et pour les
plus gourmands il y a aussi les grookies
qui sont des cookies XXL enfin format
carré un autre cadeau à offrir c'est le
kit de préparation pierre et team qui
met à disposition les ingrédients pour
préparer une douzaine de cookies bien
évidemment des cookies moelleux à
l'intérieur et croquant à l'extérieur
compte 9 € pour un kit rendez-vous sur
le site de pierre et team pour réaliser
vos
commandes